[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you mary mary j blige performs her
smash hits no more drama and family
affair during her halftime show
performance at super bowl 56 in los
angeles taking the stage alongside
fellow hip-hop heavyweights dr dre snoop
dogg eminem and kendrick lamar
[Music]
we leaving everything on the stage
that's it and that she did literally the
queen of hip-hop and soul ended her
performance of no drama in dramatic
fashion
[Music]
when it comes to the grammy winner's
outfit
she's stunned in a crystallized bodysuit
with matching thigh-high boots a look
that was teased to e.t ahead of the big
show um i think you want to give them
marry on
steroids um just like the most beautiful
glamorous
ghetto fabulous ghetto
whatever we taking it to a whole nother
level
whole another level we shine and we all
at e.t sat down with mary stylish jason
rimbert who dived into all the details
behind the singer's choice to rock the
sparkling ensemble on the world's
biggest stage
mary was feeling it from day one like i
knew the cream was gonna be hot like
like she just knew like you know
and it worked mary was very
collaborative on this like even down to
her earrings her earrings is her
clothing lines sis love it's a
jewelry line she has hoops and they're
diamond encrusted she's also wearing a
custom chain
that that she did she debuted mj b chain
so like those are the things that
is very true to her i didn't work with
any other jeweler i worked with her
and that was a great thing 2021 marked
mary's return to the music industry
after stepping away in 2010 to focus on
her acting career now the 50 year old is
back with her 15th studio album titled
good morning gorgeous it's a gorgeous
from inside and that's what we we're
manifesting beauty from the inside so we
can well do all this and be and have fun
doing it during the album's release
party earlier this week at classic cat
in west hollywood mary opened up to e.t
about her album and all the success
she's experiencing now in her career
including performing on the world's
biggest stage i'm blessed and it's a lot
of hard work
and obedience and just you know wanting
the best for myself and loving myself
and believing in myself for real
and doing the work that comes with that
because it's not easy and that's and
this is what's manifesting all these
great things that are happening you know
just the the loving on me from me that
makes everybody else love on you too
[Music]